starting the youtube now yeah brilliant
okay thank you
okay welcome to the first audit scrutiny
of 2021
um just one item on the agenda um this
time
um so if we can we'll go through quickly
any apologies for absence i've had
apologies from linda pedrick who was
going to join us because she was part of
the working group i haven't heard any
more
have we had any more chris um no
apologies but
well apologies from i suppose counselor
malone
right okay thank you um minutes of the
previous meeting
um there weren't many of us for the
previous meeting um
i'm happy to approve and sign the
minutes uh if unless i have any
dissenters
chris you happy yeah yeah i was thanking
nicole thank you very much great
any declarations of interest
nope no public quest any public
questions
nope um i've had no member questions
sent to me i don't know if you've had
any more
okay fantastic in that case
the one and only item on our agenda
today
is uh the notice of motion um
first of all i'd like to say thank you
to amanda
for her work on this uh we didn't have
that many meetings of the working group
it was fairly simple because i think
there were so few of us we
were pretty efficient we kind of knew
what we wanted to do
the brief was very simple
and i will read the recommendations
um for the benefit of anybody watching
on youtube
um the committee recommends to executive
the following on order to implement the
notice of motion motion number one
review the council's hr and equalities
practice including the provision of
equalities training for members and
officers
and our proposal is one equalities
training for members is arranged through
democratic services and members are
encouraged to attend by group leaders
two that the committee report template
is amended to include inequalities
considerations
on whether a business impact assessment
is required
three the quality the council's
equalities policy which expires in 2020
is reviewed and considered by ons and
executive and included in the 2021
forward plan
motion number five a board of
representatives from
local formerly constituted groups
representing those with protected
characters
characteristics as defined by the
equality act be formed to review the
council
equality impact assessment on the covid
recovery plan once this has been
completed
and the spotlight group to consider who
should be invited to join the board of
representatives
our proposal is members of the review
group agreed to wait until the
equality's impact assessment is
completed
then reviews then review to determine if
there are any weak areas of weakness
comments could then be sought from
external registered groups representing
the interests of that group
um okay final part of
our recommendation motion number seven
review the criteria for the councillors
community fund and recommendations
be made to ensure funding promotes
projects which address inequalities
on our proposal an additional two
questions should be included in the
council's community fund
form one how does your organizational
project meet
meet the needs of take all of any that
apply
older people young people with
disabilities members of the lgbt
community
pregnant women black asian and minority
ethnic people
and then adding further comments as well
and number two
do you have an equality's policy if you
if yes please upload a copy so those
were our
um recommendations for those three
strands
um i would be quite happy to
propose those be taken as one
recommendation rather than the separate
three strands all in one go
um before i ask for a bit of debate do i
have a seconder
a second sally thank you okay
and so we've got proposal and a second
for that record for those
recommendations
uh do we have any comments from anybody
um
bill uh thanks terry yes i was
just considering the um order of
perhaps how we might approach say in
motion number one
the proposal for equality's training and
then the bottom one number three the
council's equalities policy
now i've got a little bit of a question
about the
first of all the order because you train
to a policy and if you a policy that
changes after the training
has been done you've got to do the
training again so i think we need
the policy actually updated before you
get to the training so that
then moving on to the way training is
delivered you need to have an accurate
suitable and fail safe training needs
analysis to be able to find out exactly
what you're training
my issue with it is issue not issue but
my comment on this at the moment is
basically that
sometimes training is done because
there's a little bit of bespoke training
you can take off the shelf
and just deliver in this case i think
it's more
required to make a training needs a
analysis of exactly what you're trying
to trying to train
because it is a very tricky type of
training to deliver to some
who only need to turn up foreign
voluntarily
in the final analysis and what you come
down to really then is that it might
even be more appropriate to deliver the
organizational change
through uh monitoring or
management changes rather than training
you know what i'm trying to say
is exactly what are you trying to train
that comes from the new policy
and then how do you deliver it and then
in training terms
you've got to validate it at the end and
if it's something that's a conscious or
a
feeling or a belief that you're trying
to
adjust then you would need to look very
deeply for some type of
of validation to that training that it's
been effective at the end of it
and if we're talking about spending two
or three or maybe more thousand pounds
on training
i think we do need to follow the steps
very accurately
and to make sure we do them in the right
order and that we've got some
way of validating it which is very
tricky for this type of training
at the end of the training as well okay
thanks bill i think that's valid before
i
take um chris um
uh if we would um
anyone else like to comment on that um
um no i was going to ask um
any of our officers we've got commentary
i think the comment around
revising the equality's policy first is
a valid one i think about order i think
it would make sense to do that first
i think in terms of the training if you
recall when we had the working groups we
discussed
certain elements of training which we
haven't offered counselors before like
unconscious bias
which in our hr department because we
had an hr advisor in the working group
advised that we could do that in-house
because we've done some other training
on that for officers
and a training needs analysis
and on unequalities
and certainly we'd want
we can we can come up with some
suggestions working with hr and working
with member services around what what
things we'd want to cover and we
we did discuss that in some of the
working group certainly you'd want to
know about the policy certainly you'd
want to know about
the um the equalities legislation and
certainly i think the unconscious bias
training would be very helpful for
members as some officers have already
done that
and i guess my question would be and
this would be a member services issue do
we do a training
needs analysis for members across the
piste rather than just on the equalities
element
um or do we take the approach which is
what we take with officers is that we
offer universal training on equalities
and
it's actually compulsively for officers
that we have to do it
that's helpful yeah it's interesting
that's compulsory for officers it's not
compulsory for counsellors
yeah i think we did investigate that and
i didn't think there was any way of
we had some um debate about that and you
can't make training compulsory for
members and it was very difficult to
kind of put
a framework into place to do that yeah
yeah okay thank you thank you for that
um chris
yeah um the alterations to the council's
community fund
uh that you were perhaps suggesting with
regard to inequalities
not sure that the wording was quite
right there i mean for example
i give the burial committee
at um the churchyard money they're all
struggling to upkeep
their burial fund now anybody can be
buried in that
the the the church so we sort of to be
asking questions about the qualities
there
it sort of doesn't sit over comfortably
with me really
it it seems as though it's an
unnecessary
could the questions be put in a slightly
different slightly different wording
same with the tourists i mean i give the
tourist board
you know money we have a voluntary the
committee the tourist board but
the tourist boards are basically doing
a job for everybody one way or another
so
i'm not sure about the question somebody
put me right and
i could be written but you give it you
know put me right if i'm if i'm
if i'm wrong i think at the end of the
day we've got to ask that question
because there are some groups where it
is applicable i mean
for some i mean you know okay
but it's it's not applicable it's there
isn't it
if they don't have an equality's policy
they don't have one property
that's what i'm getting at should we add
the word if if applicable to it
but do we do we need to i don't know i
mean
we've been knocking around for a couple
of months now so
um
i think again we had a debate around
do you make that a compulsory element of
the form and in recognition of the
points of counselor clarence is making
you know we we we decided it wasn't
going to be compulsory your your
application wouldn't be excluded because
you didn't have an equalities policy
or you didn't specifically um
meet any of the the criteria that um
were listed in the proposal but i think
from a monitoring point of view we want
to make sure there's a quality of access
and for um the various protected
characteristic groups to the councillors
community funds at the moment we're
unable to monitor that because we don't
ask the question
and certainly i think you know for some
organizations it you know we should
for all organizations we should be
asking if they've got an equalities
policy i'm sure that the tourist board
may have
i'm sure that smaller groups might not
but then it gives us the opportunity as
officers to say well
you need to consider having one and
here's some you know here's some
good practice guidance on how you do
that
yeah okay i'm i'm happy with what you've
done then i mean ultimately it's up to
us as councillors what we do with our
fund money this is this is monitoring
whether
the group that we want with that we uh
donate to actually has a has a policy
and what is it
and actually those that do i'd be quite
interested to see what's in their
equality's policy because you know it's
always good to share good practice
yeah fair enough council malone you have
a question
or a comment
so did you mean me yeah i'm sorry
yeah sorry this isn't um i'm sorry i'm
not making a new point here i'm just
sort of reiterating the previous one and
it comes off
um what other people have just said um
i i'm just concerned that while i i have
no
problem with with um the intentions of
um of how we spend the councillors
community fund um
at all uh it it seems
difficult to go um to follow it in
practice
uh in covid times i mean because my last
community fund was all
i didn't nobody i've promised money to
has had any since i've become a
councillor
my last fund uh apportionment of money
was sucked into the covered fund
uh this time around i haven't yet worked
out how to how to how to do it
um and and so this you know
i i haven't given money yet to anyone
that that
i i think's a worthy cause and and i
just wonder whether
um something that's as well uh you know
as well intentioned and
you know that is as good as this but it
maybe isn't practical yet and i i'm just
concerned that we're gonna
vote for this in theory and then not do
it in practice
and people are gonna say well why did
you why did you vote for
this if you weren't gonna follow through
with it i wondered if it might be better
if it was
you know if it was enacted uh
after this emergency subsides
if it ever does
uh okay and i can i comment i think and
in the current um i think prior to to
look down there was a
there was a hold on the councillors
community fund and that was mainly
around resourcing
i think that's what that holds been
lifted before christmas and and officers
can
and i think officer did put out an email
to to members or certainly i
i remember seeing an email around
telling
members that they could and they could
then
allocate their their counselors
community fund
and i think the other the other piece of
work that's going on and
one of the other members mentioned is
around um some of the training we're
doing for members and obviously updating
the form and the process to try and
improve and the speed of applications
and getting them verified through the
cancer's community funds so i think
because that works i'm going to redo the
form and make it more electronic and and
it would be pertinent to add those
questions now
um albeit there may be there may be
situations where as i said that the
councillors community fund is put on
hold
and you know the application process
will still be there and and
the need to include those for those
questions in the forum will still be
there
yeah i appreciate that i'm just thinking
you know
with um in my case and i'm sure it's
the case with other people that um you
know
there's there's things that we've cared
about from before
that are now desperately short of funds
yeah and
and they they we haven't been able to
give them funds before i i haven't
anyway because i
i didn't um you know time ran out for my
um
for my apportionment and so it there's a
kind of backlog of things we wanted to
do
yeah and and it that there's going to be
a sort of time lag before i can
look at this i'm sure i can find very
worthy things that that that i'm
conformed to this
to this list but it's just not yet
that's all and i'm just concerned that
we
will sign up for uh for uh for a very
worthy course of action that we're not
immediately able to follow up with and
people will go
you know why did you bother with this
yeah i think i think we're not we're not
seeing as part of the process that you
need to prioritize those specific groups
but i think what we're seeing is from an
equality's monitoring point of view we
want to
make sure there's equality of access and
in order to
to um in order to do that we need to ask
those questions and we need to have that
included in the process
accepting that you know there might be
situations where
there are there are other more genetic
you know they're not dealing with a
specific one of those equalities groups
a project or whatever but they're still
accessed by
that group in general and so as i said
it's not making any conditions on how
you use the funding
it's just asking a question so that we
can monitor it and ensure that there is
access
and equally if we find that you know we
weren't giving us
a significant amount of funding or a
proportionate amount of funding to
those um types of projects we would we
would look at how we could address
that either through promotion with with
and
with groups and that um address those
concerns
and and how we improve the uptake really
but if we don't have the statistics
there
to just to to evidence what we're doing
we can't take that action
thank you who's that okay okay um
i've got uh cassidy rolison next
yeah yeah bill you need to raise your
blue hand i think so you're waiting well
we didn't earlier
i know but i just twigged that too man
um i think anton answering liam's point
that if you're in a conversation with an
organization that's worthy of support
i don't think it hurts to ask the
questions i find it
it helps people think quite a bit about
what they do and we've
referred earlier in this nomination
about
[Music]
unconscious bias and it does start to
make you think for example if you are
allowing people access to a cemetery to
bury the relatives then
you know you might wonder do you turn
anyone away or or is it one particular
group that
seem to be dominant there it makes you
wonder about equal access to any kind of
service
and and i think if us people if they've
got a policy they might consider if they
want one
it as well as what amanda says about
correct
creating a database so that we can start
working on this so i don't think it
hurts to ask the questions at all and i
don't think it should stop you giving
grants
uh i just think it starts the debate
going in the community
that's my two pennies worth thank you
and it's also a good piece of work i
have to say
i think you might have said it was
fairly easy to do those points but
i think they hit the spot really well
thank you thank you no i think you
picked the nail on it
it makes people think and that's what
we're
we're wanting to do uh nina
you're next thank you um
yeah i just i i take on board everything
um liam is saying and i think at the
moment is difficult isn't it to kind of
think about where your community funds
are gonna go um
but i think we need to remember that
this particular piece of work was
flagged
up through the gaps that we had in the
last
kind of lockdowns and as a response to
communities needs and it flagged up that
there was um
maybe a little piece of work that we
needed to do in terms of the assessment
like amanda said and
um reviewing our practice and responding
to need as it comes up and
i think what the work that manda's done
really shows
um how quickly we can respond to
communities
and um help them and give guidance as
well because part of this process is
about
looking at what's there looking at
what's changing for people but also
being able to provide the guidance where
we can as well
and even if that is for ourselves as
councillors in terms of
what is a good project and how do we
respond with our community from now
when everybody seems to be in need so i
think it is a really good piece of work
but
i don't think it's set in stone um and
like chris said if it becomes difficult
for you then
you know it is there that there are as a
list of criteria
but um if that community group doesn't
hit those criterias because it's not
applicable then
that's absolutely fine but i have the
conversations with them to support them
on um how they might change that in
future i don't know if that's helpful
but thank you and thanks amanda very
helpful thank you
um bill oh
yeah yes um thanks very much i i was
just
coming back to the business about first
of all that we
promote as the wording in the statement
and such like there which i report very
much
and we have specified that in fact it's
not restricted
to just those people that do have it
however now as we talk now i suppose the
first lot of training for the
community fund application process has
taken place
elsewhere and it's it'd be interesting
to see what it is but
i'm talking and thinking about chris's
question just now
it will be done online to start with and
we're notified
after it has been applied for by one of
our
residents and then we authorize it also
online afterwards
now the thing about it is is
it'll be interesting to see if how soon
we could get these
questions on to the new application
process
um i wonder whether in fact we ought to
have a little bit of uh
an attachment to the online forum that
allows people to
consider perhaps a more um already
or a test equalities policy that might
be
suitable for a small organization
just so that in fact they can be
actively encouraged towards having
something like this
as early as possible and to encourage
them
each and every one to to to include it
in their
community articles or whatever they call
them
but i i i it's i think it's on the right
lines i'm just
worried whether in fact we might agree
to something and then it takes a long
while to introduce it to the community
um application form that's the thing
online
well we've we've got a amanda here
well it's interesting because it's in
one of my officers that's doing the
training on the new form
and i've already asked them as a preempt
to
obviously include the questions and the
hope that it's going to be ratified by
executive
rule council because actually it's
easier to take them out than it is to
add them
as you've identified retrospectively so
they are
they are already there as a
consideration and and they can be done
and the way the form is um constructed
it it's less than half an hour's work
probably for an officer to add them in
so that wouldn't be a problem
thank you uh mary
yeah um yeah i go along with
everything that's been said i do think
we should include those questions on the
forum and go along with that
but i would just say that when i've
given my community fund out
in the past it's certainly never entered
my head
to sort of differentiate between who i'm
giving it to
so to me um
we're asking questions now that before
it never entered my head that we needed
to ask those
questions i just it didn't matter to me
where what uh where people came from
the money went just the same if the
cause was good
so i just think that in the past i've
done this anyway
without a question on the form but you
know if
we feel that that's beneficial in the
future fine go along with it
thank you i think it is i think i think
we still recognize that we're going to
give our community funds
where the need is most this enables us
to monitor
um a little bit more effectively um
who's getting it and whether people are
actually thinking about the equalities
of their organization
so it's it's an extra an extra string to
our bow i think as a council and it
makes us think you know it you know
amanda talked about training for
unconscious bias we're all guilty of it
and perhaps in this case even more
because we don't think we look at need
first we don't look at other things
that might be important to other people
who are not in our privileged position
so
um i i think it's a welcome addition to
um to the form um i must admit
i got rid of i i spent my community fund
before
the new came out um i i actually gave
all my money to the primary school
because they were so
desperate for funds with the extra
mitigation and money they had to spend
on on
you know uh covered mitigation practices
that they they were desperate so they
they
they've had it so um i'll still do the
training obviously of course but um
none left in mine until april um
but i think it's very welcome and uh and
i think i think the training that we're
having on this is it's more technical
isn't it rather than yeah than what's
actually
um the content um so
you know i'm i'm i'm very happy with
this recommendation um
we we did we you know we did fresh it
out quite
effectively i think as a group when we
discussed it
uh and we came back with some ideas and
i think amanda has done really well
putting it all together for us
um so do we oh liam you've got your hand
up again
yeah sorry i uh um i i just was
interested but something you said um
not trying to catch you out but you said
you man you gave your money to the
primary school
i thought that wasn't allowed because
they're run by
devon cc no because i i i
my local school at decoy is similarly on
its knees and i
would like to help them out if i could
if it's for a specific project that
doesn't usually come under normal school
budgets
for example it's not part of their
revenue budget for paying staff whatever
what then then yes you can because
bubbe school desperately needs an
outdoor shelter and they've provided
outdoor washing facilities which has
cost them a lot of money
and we need an outdoor shelter and
that's a specific project that wouldn't
usually be funded by the county funds
so as that's additional that is allowed
right thank you okay
uh anymore for any more any more
questions or comments no
okay well thank you all for that we've
had
i've made the proposal we've had a
second from
councillor rolison for the
recommendations
uh can we go to the vote please i think
probably a roll call should we do a roll
call for this chris as it is
i think that's probably going to be
executive this recommendation will go to
the executive
thank you chair um councillor clarence
paul councillor colclough hello
councillor goodman bradbury four
councillor cox four
councillor morgan councillor malone
paul councillor rolison paul
and councillor thorne or that's
unanimous chair
brilliant thank you very much um so that
will now
go to the executive where they will
discuss it and we can join them if we
wish and
witness their discussions um thank you
amanda for putting this together thank
you to everybody who was part of the
working group and obviously
linda who um was part of the group as
well um
linda pederick um she was happy to um
obviously endorse this as she was part
of the group so thank you very much for
uh all of the work that we've put into
this um obviously
like like we've said it it's a work in
progress we won't get things right first
time
we've um discussed it there might be
things we need to tweak in the future
but i i think we've um actually
made a you know a positive contribution
here um so thank you very much
and thank you nina for joining us this
morning as well but uh
thank you very much and uh i'll leave
you to get on with the rest of your day
and those of you who are teaching your
children at home
good luck i'm glad mine's now 22 and i
don't have to do it anymore
[Laughter]
thank you